[موسيقى
] يمكن أن يكون التمرين مكثفًا
بالنسبة للبعض ، حيث يبدأ النضال في
العثور على الزي المناسب
الذي يجب أن تكون مرتاحًا عليه
طوال اليوم سواء كنت تدرب شخصًا
آخر أو تدرب نفسك على البحث عن
معدات رياضية ، كان
المدرب الشخصي تشاي ليون
هندريكس صعبًا للغاية.  لم يتمكن من العثور على ملابس تلائم
شكل جسمه الرياضي إلى أن
صادف ذئب القرفصاء شركة ناشئة متخصصة في ملابس الصالة الرياضية ،
فلديك بعض
المواد التي تسمح بمرور الهواء والتي تسمح لك بالبقاء في الهواء الطلق
ولكنك ما زلت تشعر بالانتعاش
وكل ما هناك من مجموعة متنوعة  المواد
التي يستخدمونها والتي أستمتع بارتدائها
في دبي في عام 2016 من قبل
مراقب الزوجين الباكستانيين
وأنام خالد سكوات وولف لديها
هدف محدد ،
نحن ماركة ملابس رياضية فاخرة
للرياضيين ، نصنع معدات للرياضيين ذوي
اللياقة البدنية الحقيقية التي يمكنك استخدامها بالضبط
إنها قطعة انتقالية على عكس بعض
العلامات التجارية الرياضية التي أنتجت بكميات كبيرة
للمستهلكين ، وقد صنع الذئب القرفصاء
مكانة خاصة به مع التركيز فقط على الملابس
المصممة  تم تخصيصه للرياضيين في صالة الألعاب
الرياضية وشاي ليون ، يلعب المؤثر الصغير
دورًا رئيسيًا في
استراتيجية التسويق للشركة للتنافس ضد
العمالقة العالميين
عندما بدأنا العلامة التجارية لأننا
نعلم أن لدينا ميزانية محدودة للإنفاق ،
لذلك كنا نلاحق الشخصية
المدربين الذين عرفناهم
في الصالات الرياضية وسألناهم عما إذا كنت
ترغب في دعم علامة تجارية محلية ،
فالأمر كله يتعلق بإنشاء مجتمع
واستخدام الرياضيين المحليين مثل تشاي ليون
للإعلان عن العلامة التجارية على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي مما
جلب المزيد من الإيرادات والمصداقية
التي نستخدمها للإعلان
الإعلان الرقمي والإعلانات الرقمية والتسويق
أيضًا وعندما ترى الوجوه المألوفة
في ملف الأخبار الخاص بك تظهر ، أعلم أن
هذا الرجل قد رأيت هذا الرجل في صالة الألعاب الرياضية ،
أعلم أن هذا الرجل قام بتدريب صديقي ،
إنه مدربي بالفعل والناس في
النهاية  ابدأ في الوثوق بعلامتهم التجارية
وابدأ باستخدام هذه
الإستراتيجية المحلية والمصممة خصيصًا للمساعدة في تحويل القرفصاء جيدًا
من علامة تجارية مقتصرة على دبي فقط إلى شركة
ناشئة صحية لرياضيين الصالة الرياضية  في أكثر
من 120 دولة ،
مما يمهد الطريق أمام
الشركات الصغيرة الطموحة للنجاح في سوق شديدة
التنافسية
ومساعدة شاي ليون على وضع أفضل ما
في الصالة الرياضية التي قمت بها اليوم
[موسيقى]